- Welcome, everyone.
This is the second of a
two-part lecture series,
the 2023 Castle Lecture series.
For those who were not here yesterday,
I am pleased to introduce our
speaker today, Ben Wizner,
who is the director
of the ACLU Speech Privacy
and Technology Project.
Yesterday, Ben started to build up
the foundations of his argument
and deliver an engaging and
thought-provoking account
of a Freedom of Information Act lawsuit
seeking to release a few
dozen pages of records
from the Guantanamo Bay prison.
This lawsuit, as he argued,
illustrates how the national security law
affects democratic accountability.
Today, Ben will continue
his critical analysis
of the national security law.
And as I mentioned yesterday,
the Castle Lectures aim
to promote awareness
of the ethical challenges and
complexities of our society,
and foster a robust dialogue
of the moral foundations
of society and government.
This lecture series were made possible
because of a generous gift by John Castle,
who is in the audience with us today.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much.
We are grateful for the
support of Mr. Castle,
both to the EPME program,
and for Yale more broadly.
This gift was made in
honor of his ancestor,
Rev. James Pierpont,
a Harvard-trained congressional minister
who founded the Collegiate
School of Connecticut in 1701,
soon thereafter renamed for
its benefactor, Elihu Yale.
We are very grateful to Ben
for accepting the invitation
to deliver this Yale lecture,
and for his willingness to
discuss with our community
such a relevant and complex topic
as the interconnection
of national security
and democratic accountability.
The format of today's lecture
is going to be the same as yesterday.
So Ben will talk for about 50 minutes,
and then we're gonna have
plenty of time for Q&A.
So I please ask you to welcome
me in giving Ben the floor.
Ben, thank you so much
for being with us today.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much, Anna,
for that kind introduction again,
and thank you all for being
here, especially those
who I'm seeing for the
second day in a row.
If anything, to those of you who are new,
seems underdeveloped,
it's simply because you
weren't here yesterday.
(audience laughing)
In September of 2011,
Harvard Law School and
the Brookings Institution,
which publishes the "Lawfare" blog,
a kind of online clubhouse
for the National Security set,
hosted a two-day conference
to mark the 10 year anniversary
of the 9/11 attacks.
Among the event's
luminaries was John Brennan,
at that time, Obama's chief
counterterrorism advisor,
and later the director
of Central Intelligence,
who delivered a lunchtime keynote address.
I joined the queue of people
waiting to ask him a question,
and when my turn came I asked,
does the CIA have a drone program?
The audience erupted in laughter.
Brennan responded, "Well,
as you know, covert actions
are designed to be covert and therefore."
"And therefore you only read
about them in the newspaper,"
I interrupted.
"If the agency did have such a program,"
he said to more laughter,
"I'm sure it would be done
with the utmost care and precision
in accordance with the law and our values
if such a program existed."
At the close of yesterday's lecture,
we discussed the legal
fiction that forms the pillar
of the intelligence
community's impunity regime,
that there is a critical distinction
between what is universally known,
and what is officially confirmed.
Anyone unfamiliar with that fiction
would've been bewildered by
my exchange with Brennan.
Wasn't the CIA's drone program
in newspapers almost every day?
And weren't those stories
essentially readouts
from government sources?
Two weeks after the Harvard
Conference, Anwar al-Awlaki,
a US citizen born in
Las Cruces, New Mexico,
was killed in Yemen by a hellfire missile
fired from a US predator drone.
This targeted killing came as no surprise.
The entire world knew
that the United States had
marked al-Awlaki for death
nearly two years earlier.
That's because in early 2010,
senior Obama administration officials,
in a coordinated media strategy,
leaked to leading
newspapers that al-Awlaki
had been added to secret kill lists
maintained by the CIA and
Department of Defense's
Joint Special Operations Command.
These off-the-record leaks
were a deliberate policy decision.
The Obama administration wanted the public
to know of its controversial decision
to target a US citizen for death
based on undisclosed
criteria and evidence.
In national security law,
we always arrive, sooner or later,
at the bottom of a previously
announced slippery slope.
At oral argument before the
Fourth Circuit Court of Appeals
in the al-Masri case, which
I discussed yesterday,
I had warned the court
that if al-Masri's claims
of kidnapping and torture
could be dismissed on secrecy grounds,
then the state secrets privilege
will be employed routinely
to shield from liability
even the most egregious acts.
The government could and would
make the identical argument,
even if the claim involved
extrajudicial murder,
and even if the plaintiff
were an American citizen.
Could and would and did.
In August of 2010,
the ACLU and the Center
for Constitutional Rights
responded to the slew of
news stories announcing
that al-Awlaki had been added
to government kill lists
by filing a lawsuit,
challenging the government's
asserted authority
to carry out targeted
killings of US citizens
located far from any armed conflict zone.
The US was not at war with
Yemen or within it, we argued,
and outside of armed conflict,
both the Constitution
and international law
prohibited deliberate killing,
except as a last resort
to protect against concrete,
specific, and imminent threats.
An extrajudicial killing policy
under which names were
added to kill lists,
shopping lists for death,
through some kind of
secret executive process,
and remain there for months,
was plainly not limited
to imminent threats.
And because al-Awlaki was a US citizen,
he had a due process right
to know what conduct might
subject him to execution
at the hands of his own government.
In response to our
lawsuit, the government,
having deliberately
invited a public debate
about its asserted
authority to kill al-Awlaki,
now decided that having
that debate in a courtroom
would reveal state secrets
and damage national security.
In a sworn declaration,
Secretary of Defense Robert Gates
insisted that quote,
"disclosure of whether or not
lethal force has been authorized
to combat a terrorist
organization overseas,
and if so, the specific
targets of such action,
would provide the nation's enemies
with critical information
needed to evade hostile action."
This was head spinning.
If it was true,
it was quite obviously
the administration's leaks
and not our lawsuit that
had created that danger.
This pattern, placing information
into the public sphere,
and then claiming secrecy when
faced with legal challenge
is an all too common feature
of national security law in practice.
In February of 2008,
I was in a federal court
in San Jose, California
arguing against the dismissal of a lawsuit
brought by five victims
of the CIA's rendition
and torture program.
The basis for the
government's motion to dismiss
was a sworn declaration by
CIA director Michael Hayden
insisting that any confirmation or denial
of the lawsuit's allegations
would disclose state secrets
and damage national security.
On that very same day,
Hayden himself was
testifying before Congress,
and disclosing officially
for the first time
that the CIA had
waterboarded three prisoners.
I should add, just two months before that,
Hayden had written in a
letter to CIA employees
that the CIA had destroyed 92 videotapes
depicting enhanced
interrogation techniques
because the CIA had determined
that they were not relevant
to any congressional
or judicial proceeding.
This is the expertise to
which courts obligingly defer.
The government's legal
fictions around secrecy
can produce some amusing results.
In November of 2010, WikiLeaks
and its media partners
began publishing a quarter of a million
confidential State Department cables
that they had obtained from
Army private Chelsea Manning.
Hundreds of thousands
of government employees and contractors
were immediately warned by their superiors
not to view the cables.
Even those published in full
by "The New York Times"
and other media outlets
because they might lack the
proper clearance to do so.
I was under no such injunction,
and I found some pretty interesting cables
describing the diplomatic fallout
from the CIA's rendition
and torture programs,
from Guantanamo, and from drone strikes.
In 2011, the ACLU submitted a FOIA request
to the State Department
for 23 of those cables.
There was an element of
mischief in this request.
It was the first and only time
we had used the FOIA to ask for documents
that we literally
already held in our hand,
but we were curious, what
would the State Department do?
Would they continue to
withhold the cables in full?
Would they bow to reality
and declassify them,
or would they process the request
by redacting what they deemed sensitive
and releasing the rest?
If you chose option C, hats off to you.
Sure enough, the State Department
sent us redacted versions
of 11 of the cables
offering a rare roadmap of
their classification process.
The ACLU created a web
feature that allowed readers
to hover the mouse over
the redacted portions
to see exactly what had been removed.
This included a reference to allegations
of Italian prosecutors
that a US military jet had
traversed Swiss airspace
on the day that the CIA
kidnapped cleric Abu Omar from
Milan, that was no secret.
Two years earlier an Italian court
had convicted in absentia 23 Americans,
most of them CIA operatives,
for their role in his abduction
and rendition to Egypt
where he was tortured.
Also redacted was a cable
describing the pressure the
US had placed on Germany
to shut down a criminal investigation
into the CIA's kidnapping
of Khalid al-Masri
and another explaining how
the Abu Ghraib torture scandal
had made the US less secure.
I called this result amusing,
but in secrecy disputes,
the government gets the last laugh.
We argued in court that by
processing our FOIA request,
the government had acknowledged
that the cables were authentic.
That meant, or should have meant,
that the State Department
could no longer hang its hat
on the distinction between what was known
and what was confirmed,
and should now be compelled
to declassify the cables in full.
But a federal court sided
with the government.
because our FOIA request
had listed the cables by date and number,
and had not specifically
mentioned WikiLeaks,
the State Department had
actually admitted nothing
by processing our request,
they might be different cables together.
Of course,
the court could reach this
embarrassing conclusion
only by refusing to take 30 seconds
to look at the cables
published by WikiLeaks
and those held by the
government side by side.
John Brennan's cheeky
refusal to acknowledge
the CIA's drone program
was a hit at Harvard.
The academic audience
appreciated being in on the joke,
but the game the government
plays in these cases
is corrosive and damaging.
By deploying selective leaks to the press,
and secrecy claims to the courts,
the government can simultaneously
manipulate public debate
and avoid accountability and oversight.
And of course the flip side
of impunity for insiders
is strict liability for dissenters.
The Espionage Act of 1917,
the principle vehicle
for prosecuting national security leaks,
does not distinguish between
unauthorized leaks to the press
in the public interest,
and the sale of secrets
to foreign enemies,
which is to say it doesn't
distinguish between
sources and spies.
In fact, in a recent leak prosecution,
the Department of Justice
took the remarkable position
that unauthorized leaks to the press
were more pernicious than
the typical espionage case
where a spy sells classified
information for money,
because when information
appears in the press,
every foreign adversary, and
not just one, stood to benefit.
All too often national security elites
regard the American public
as their adversaries,
and place their own interests
ahead of the values of an open society.
It's understandable that
in the immediate aftermath
of a national trauma like 9/11,
courts would give the executive branch
a longer leash on matters
of national security.
What's harder to explain
is how this excessive judicial deference
amounting to de facto impunity
has endured and entrenched
itself over time.
In a speech at Hebrew
University in Jerusalem in 1987,
the late justice William Brennan lamented
the shabby treatment civil
liberties have received
in the United States in times of war,
or perceived threats to national security.
He described a cyclical pattern.
In an atmosphere of crisis,
courts would be in his words,
reluctant to question the factual bases
underlying asserted security threats,
and would defer to executive demands
that liberties be temporarily curtailed.
After each perceived
security crisis ended,
Brennan observed the United
States has remorsefully realized
that the abrogation of civil
liberties was unnecessary,
and the claimed dangers
wildly exaggerated.
Quote, "The rumors of French
intrigue during the 1790s,
the claims that civilian courts
were unable to adjudicate
the allegedly treasonous
actions of northerners
during the Civil War.
The hysterical belief
that criticism of conscription
and the war effort
might lead droves of
soldiers to desert the army
or resist the draft during World War I,
the wild assertions of
sabotage or espionage
by Japanese Americans during World War II,
and the paranoid fear that
the American Communist Party
stood ready to overthrow the government,
were all so baseless that
they would be comical
were it not for the serious
hardship that they caused
during the time of crisis," Brennan noted.
Nevertheless, the country had proved
unable to break this cycle
because Brennan believed the
crises were too infrequent
and the country too tranquil
for courts to develop the expertise
to scrutinize claimed threats.
Quote, "A jurisprudence capable
of braving the overblown
claims of national security
must be forged in times of crisis
by the sort of intimate familiarity
with national security threats
that tests their bases in fact,
explores their relation to the
exercise of civil freedoms,
and probes the limits of
their compass," he insisted.
In this way he hoped adversity
could be the handmaiden of liberty.
If Justice Brennan had been correct,
if courts simply needed more exposure
to national security claims
to develop the institutional
capability to assess them,
then the last two decades
should have provided it.
But it now seems clear
that Justice Brennan's
optimism was misplaced.
Have courts learned to
test the factual bases
of claimed national security threats?
To the contrary,
they've doubled down on
a doctrine of deference
that insist on their own
institutional incompetence
to second guess security officials.
Have courts explored the
relation of asserted threats
to the exercise of civil freedoms?
To the contrary,
they've treated national
security interests as absolute,
and resisted a jurisprudence
of proportionality
that would contextualize threats
and weigh competing values.
Have courts probed the
limits of the compass
of the government's claims of crisis?
To the contrary,
they've acquiesced to
a definition of crisis
wholly lacking in temporal
or geographic constraints,
a conflict that takes place
everywhere and forever.
Justice Brennan assumed
that national crises
would be defined or at least definable.
He had in mind wars or conflicts
of fixed duration and scope.
The post-9/11 National Security Project,
with its focus on countering
terrorist threats,
has in the words of one scholar
identified the perfect conceptual vehicle
for a permanent mobilization
of the security state.
And national security law in
the age of counterterrorism
has made judicial abdication
not the cyclical exception
that Justice Brennan described,
but an entrenched norm that
John Brennan no doubt prefers.
That courts have embraced
this diminished role,
and if anything, deepened
their commitment to deference
despite the absence of
a major terrorist attack
on US soil since 9/11,
is a testament to the success
of national security elites
in enshrining into law a
permanent state of exception.
What is national security?
The term is overused and under-analyzed.
And it's so rotely intoned
in so many contexts
that it's been drained
of almost all meaning.
In his memoir, Graham Greene
tells the story of a friend
who, at her father's funeral,
is urged by an elderly priest
to return to the church.
"Remind me," she asked the priest,
"what are the arguments
for the existence of God?"
"I knew them once," replies the priest,
"but I've forgotten them."
(audience laughs)
There's something similarly ritualistic
in the way we invoke national security
without attending to
the meaning of the words
or to what they do or don't encompass.
Victor Klemperer, in
a much darker context,
described how words, idioms,
and sentence structures
can be imposed on a people
in a million repetitions,
and taken on board
mechanically and unconsciously.
In Klemperer's understanding,
the process is a closed system
for undermining meaning.
By forcing a public debate using words
and even categories of its own invention,
a government can manufacture consent
through the manufacture of language.
The press, merely by doing its job,
amplifies the new terminology.
Even if it does so critically,
it writes the concept into being.
National security has entered
our collective bloodstream
through these endless repetitions
and has enshrined itself as
a defining national interest
without being clearly defined.
I don't mean to suggest
that the law provides no
definitions, there are many,
but over time, the definitional
scope of national security
has been continually revised and expanded
to include other
recapitulated terminology,
like Homeland Security
or counter-terrorism.
National security is now understood
to encompass national defense
functions on one side,
and domestic law enforcement
functions on the other.
With few, if any, limiting principles.
And because national
security law came into being
in the Cold War context of an
existential nuclear threat,
once we place the national security label
on a government function,
a distinct set of rules and
expectations comes with it.
For example, we've long understood
that in our constitutional system,
even murder suspects must walk free
if police or prosecutors break the rules.
But when the context is national security,
our risk tolerance evaporates,
and we conjure a new category of people
who cannot be released,
even to enforce fundamental rights
or vindicate core values.
The Guantanamo prison remains open
in part because during the brief window
when the Obama administration
could have emptied it,
its own interagency task force concluded
that 48 of the prisoners
could neither be prosecuted nor released.
"They couldn't be prosecuted,"
the task force candidly stated,
"either because there was insufficient
admissible evidence of guilt,"
meaning evidence that had
not been beaten out of them,
or "because their conduct
did not constitute
a chargeable offense," meaning
they had committed no crime.
And they couldn't be released,
in the task force's words,
because "they posed a
national security threat
that cannot be sufficiently mitigated
through feasible and
appropriate security measures."
What does that sentence mean?
My question is sincere, not rhetorical.
Cannot be released in what sense?
Why do we casually accept the assertion
that the release of any
individual, any 50 individuals,
poses a national security threat
that requires indefinite detention
by the most powerful
military in human history?
What kind of threat?
Is our global surveillance apparatus
incapable of keeping an
eye on a few dozen people
who have been in our custody
for a decade, now two?
Does the risk that some
might rejoin the Taliban
or even Al-Qaeda, create so great a danger
that we have no reasonable alternative
to locking them away forever?
In short, why isn't a statement like this
greeted with incredulity, even mockery?
To be sure, the decision to continue
the Guantanamo indefinite detention regime
has drawn considerable criticism,
including from the legal academy.
That criticism has rightly taken issue
with the legal basis
for prolonged detention,
and has challenged the assertion
that the military response
authorized by Congress
in the aftermath of 9/11
includes the authority
to hold people forever,
or until terrorism has been
defeated, whichever comes first.
You can laugh.
(audience laughs)
But we rarely hear criticism
of the childish premise
that terror suspects are supervillains
who will scatter death
like dandelion seeds
if sprung from their cages.
You're far more likely to
hear Guantanamo opponents
insist that in no conceivable scenario
will Abu Zubayda be allowed to
walk the streets of Chicago.
If he can't be convicted
in a federal court,
he'll be put in immigration detention
and deported immediately.
This motive argument has
surely been strategic.
I've used it myself,
but I've come to regard it as misguided.
By not objecting to the
hyperbolic threat inflation
that's deployed to
justify lawless actions,
by not insisting on a taxonomy
of national security threats
that distinguishes the
existential from the routine,
we drastically narrow the range of options
that are deemed reasonable
by the public policy makers
and ultimately the courts.
We get trapped in that
claustrophobic fallacy
familiar to anyone who
opposed the invasion of Iraq
20 years ago this month,
but what would you do
about Saddam's weapons
of mass destruction?
A few years ago I pulled
into an upstate rest area
on the New York state throughway
on a quiet summer afternoon
and picked up a brochure
from an information kiosk.
Published by a state
law enforcement agency,
it was headlined, know the
eight signs of terrorism,
and it urged the public to be vigilant
for telltale indicators.
Be on the lookout for people
who are taking pictures
or making drawings.
Watch for people who are in
places they should not be,
and people who don't fit
into the daily routine of your community.
Be especially on guard for the dry run.
Described as putting people into position
and moving them around
without actually committing
a terrorist attack.
A quick internet search
reveals that versions of this document,
our generation's duck and cover,
have been republished and distributed
by law enforcement agencies
across the country.
Americans everywhere, it
would seem, are being enlisted
to conjure dark fantasies
from routine observations.
My sense is that documents like these
are aimed not only at the
public, but at the police,
the state and local law
enforcement agencies
that long to be part of the action.
The cops on the beat who
are invited to identify
as warriors in the great struggle.
Not only in Manhattan and Los Angeles,
but in police departments nationwide,
suburban and rural officers
are sitting in training rooms
looking at slide decks that
depict ordinary American scenes
and being initiated
into the apparitional
world of counterterrorism.
Another kind of threat conjuring
took place in Hollywood
soon after the 9/11 attacks,
as described breathlessly
in the Hollywood Insider
publication, "The Wrap,"
a lot of what transpired that
night is still top secret,
but this much we do know.
One evening in October, 2001,
just weeks after Al-Qaeda terrorists
took down the Twin Towers in Manhattan
and maimed the Pentagon,
a group of about 30 of
Hollywood's top creatives,
A-listers like Oliver Stone,
"Law and Order" producer Dick Wolf,
"Seven" director David Fincher,
"NYPD Blues'" David Milch,
and the late John Singleton,
to name just a few, were quietly invited
to mingle with high-level
members of the US military.
The group was officially, though secretly,
named the entertainment
industry task force,
and its mission, which everyone accepted,
was to help America prevent another 9/11
by brainstorming terrorist scenarios
so out of the box crazy,
they could only happen in the movies,
unless, that is, Al-Qaeda
thought of them first.
The first meeting began
at around seven pm,
didn't break up until
sometime before midnight.
Attendees had so many
horrifyingly destructive
and diabolical ideas,
they decided to meet
again a few weeks later
for a second session.
All signed non-disclosure agreements
swearing them to secrecy,
and while there were whispers
in Hollywood newsrooms
about some sort of hush-hush
summit, nobody blabbed a word.
I want to believe that
this wasn't serious,
that the high-level military officials
saw an excuse to mingle with celebrities,
that Hollywood's overgrown man-children
got their chance to playact initiation
into the world of covert operations,
that the memo that was
produced from these meetings
was quietly placed in
a dusty file cabinet,
no doubt, with top secret
stamped on every page.
I wanna believe that,
but I remember too well
the years of relentless
color-coded threat warnings
based on chatter about impending attacks.
The announcements made with great fanfare
that ludicrous plots had been disrupted.
A dirty bomber whose plan was
to place uranium in a bucket
and swing it around his
body to create a centrifuge.
A clownish conspiracy to
topple the Sears Tower
into Lake Michigan to create a tsunami.
Vice President Dick Cheney
described that last one
as a very real threat.
A key ingredient in the
shrill fearmongering
that has characterized the
post 9/11 security regime
is a deep desire on the
part of its participants
to identify as actors in an epical event.
One could fairly describe this
as a form of identity politics.
As George Packer wrote
a decade after 9/11,
with perhaps some measure of mea culpa,
"At the time of the attacks,
few educated Americans born after 1950
had any direct experience
of war or persecution
or a cataclysmic failure.
After 9/11, this gap in the
resumes of intellectuals
gave them both a sense of inadequacy,
an outbreak of envy for
the greatest generation,
and a compensatory tendency
to inflate the drama
of the war on terror and
their own role in it."
In a lecture in this room six years ago,
I discussed the way the identity needs
of these would-be warriors
have created an inverted
politics of national security.
Those who proclaim that today's terrorists
represent an unprecedented
threat to our way of life,
that our existing laws,
courts, and institutions,
even our prisons, are inadequate
in the face of this threat,
that we have no choice but to
dispense with core principles,
including even the
prohibition against torture,
to defeat this ruthless enemy.
That in short, 9/11 changed everything.
It is these fantasists who are extolled
as hard-nosed realists,
the warriors who are willing
to take the gloves off.
By contrast, those who defend
the vitality and viability
of our constitutional system,
who insist that our existing institutions
are equal to the challenges
posed by transnational terrorism
who demand that we abide
by core commitments,
including fair trials for and
humane treatment of prisoners.
It is these cool-headed
un-panicked persons
who are dismissed as weak and naive,
afflicted by a pre-9/11 mindset.
That distorted worldview
allows the judiciary to view
its own abdication of oversight
as an expression of solidarity.
Solidarity with the strong and the wise
rather than professional weakness.
In case after case, I and my colleagues
encountered federal judges
who were astonished,
sometimes even angered, by our suggestion
that they carefully scrutinize
the claims of national security officials.
One case stands out.
My ACLU colleagues challenged
the constitutionality of a law
that authorized the government to monitor
Americans' international phone
calls and emails en masse,
so long as the targets of the surveillance
were not US persons, and
were reasonably believed
to be outside the United States.
The plaintiffs were lawyers, journalists,
human rights researchers, and
others, whose communications
were very likely to be
swept up under the law,
and who had been compelled
to take burdensome steps
to protect the confidentiality
of sensitive information.
Naturally, the question before
the courts was not whether
the constitution permitted
this mass surveillance program,
but whether our plaintiffs
were permitted to challenge it.
The government moved for summary judgment
on the ground that
plaintiffs lacked standing
because they couldn't show
that their own communications
had been surveilled.
This is a standard catch 22,
in challenges to National
Security surveillance laws.
Even if the law's scope is public,
its specific targets are secret,
so the government can
prevent any plaintiff
from testing its constitutionality.
A federal district judge
agreed with the government,
but a three-judge panel
of the Second Circuit Court of Appeals,
including Yale's own
Guido Calabresi, reversed,
holding that the
plaintiffs had demonstrated
a reasonable fear
that their communications
would be monitored,
which was sufficient
to establish standing.
The full Second Circuit then split
six to six on the question.
With six judges agreeing that
our case could go forward,
and the other six siding
with the government.
Judge Dennis Jacobs joined his colleagues
who believed the lawsuit
should be dismissed,
but he wrote separately to convey
just how offended he was
at being asked to decide.
The lawsuit's allegations were inadequate,
implausible, and illusory, he wrote.
The challenged law concerned
only the surveillance of persons abroad
who are not United States
citizens or residents.
So the claim that plaintiffs
might be implicated quote,
"Bears similarity to a pro
se plaintiff's allegation
that the CIA is controlling him
through a radio embedded in his molar.
At the risk of being
obvious," he continued,
The purpose of this lawsuit is
litigation for its own sake.
"For these lawyers to claim
a role in policy making
for which they were not
appointed or elected.
For which they are no
fitted by experience,
and for which they are not accountable.
As best I can see, the only
purpose of this litigation
is for counsel and plaintiffs
to act out their fantasy of persecution,
to validate their pretensions
to policy expertise,
to make themselves consequential
rather than marginal,
and to raise funds for
self-sustaining litigation.
In short, counsel's and plaintiffs
only perceptible interest
is to carve out for themselves
an influence over government policy,
an interest that the law
of standing forecloses."
Two things are striking about this tirade.
The first is that
the lawyers were not claiming
a role for themselves.
They were trying to claim
a role for Judge Jacobs.
Congress had enacted a law,
the president had signed it,
in asking a court to determine
whether the political branches
had overstepped constitutional boundaries,
the ACLU was not usurping
a policymaking role.
We were invoking a judicial one.
The second is that the ACLU
and our plaintiffs were right,
and Judge Jacobs quite wrong
about the law in question.
We did not learn this through
the litigation, of course.
The Supreme Court sided with Judge Jacobs
ending the case before it could begin.
We learned it through a
spectacular act of law breaking.
When Edward Snowden shared
classified documents with journalists.
It turned out that under
the putative authority
of the challenged law,
the NSA had engaged in what it
calls upstream surveillance,
which involves placing
surveillance equipment
on the internet's central arteries,
and systematically
intercepting and copying
private email messages,
phone calls, and other data
flowing in and out of the country,
and then searching that data
with thousands of keywords
that are never approved by any judge.
Even the government's more
targeted use of the law
to obtain the communications
of specific foreigners
swept up the communications
of many Americans.
In July of 2014, the "Washington Post"
published a deeply reported investigation
into surveillance under the 2008 law
based on a cache of 160,000
intercepted communications.
Ordinary internet users far outnumber
illegally targeted foreigners,
the "Post" revealed,
and nearly half of the surveillance files,
a strikingly high proportion,
contained names, email
addresses, or other details
that the NSA marked
as belonging to US citizens or residents.
Our plaintiff's allegations
were very far from implausible.
We strongly suspected, but
could not know that at the time,
but some observers knew.
One of them was Edward Snowden,
who saw the Supreme Court's
dismissal of our case
on justiciability grounds
as a final piece of evidence
that national security checks
and balances were broken.
Less than three months later,
he walked out of an NSA facility in Hawaii
carrying the evidence that
courts had refused to look at.
The irony is that had the federal courts
deigned to consider our claims
rather than dismiss them
without adjudication,
they might have prevented
the most consequential unauthorized leak
in the nation's history.
In June of 2013, when "The
Guardian" and "Washington Post"
published their first blockbuster stories
based on documents provided
by Edwards Snowden,
President Obama responded testily,
"The newly disclosed
surveillance programs,
including the revelation
that the government
was collecting metadata
from virtually all US phone
calls on an ongoing daily basis
should be of no concern
to Americans because,"
the President insisted,
"they were conducted
under very strict supervision
by all three branches of government.
We've got congressional oversight
and judicial oversight,"
he said, "and if people can't trust
not only the executive branch,
but also don't trust Congress
and don't trust federal judges
to make sure that we're
abiding by the Constitution
due process and rule of law,
then we're going to have
some problems here."
The president's claim that all
three branches of government
were involved in monitoring
the surveillance activities
was generally accurate, but
far from being a defense,
it would prove to be a deep
source of embarrassment
for anyone who had argued
that legal oversight of
national security programs
was functional and effective.
That's because the activities
that had been approved in secret
failed to survive public scrutiny.
Stung by sunlight, all
three branches of government
felt compelled to change
course, sometimes dramatically.
The president appointed a panel
of senior intelligence
officials and legal experts
to conduct a comprehensive review
of intelligence surveillance practices,
and the panel recommended
46 sweeping reforms,
some of which were adopted
just months after the president's remarks.
For the first and only time
in my two decades at the ACLU,
the federal courts did
not dismiss our lawsuit
challenging the legality
of an intelligence surveillance program
on standing or secrecy grounds.
Instead, the Second Circuit
Court of Appeals ruled
that the NSA's mass collection
of Americans' call records
was illegal, and had always been illegal,
And for the first time since the 1970s,
Congress enacted legislation that reduced
rather than expanded the
surveillance authorities
of the intelligence community.
No one has plausibly argued
that any of these
reforms would've occurred
if Snowden had not shared
classified documents with the press.
I think some of the
condescension and disdain
with which Snowden is viewed
in national security circles
is attributable to the awkward fact
that the only significant reforms
to intelligence surveillance
laws in modern American history
have been initiated by
leaks and law breaking,
not by the system's supposedly
rigorous checks and balances.
That's why I have little
patience for those who scold
that Snowden should
have raised his concerns
through the system.
What system do people think
they're talking about?
What's the proper channel
for reporting that the
intelligence community
developed and deployed a
global mass surveillance system
with the blessing of all
three branches of government,
but without public consultation?
The truth is that Snowden did vastly more
to reform intelligence
surveillance practices
by breaking the law,
than I and my colleagues did
by requesting politely
that courts enforce it.
I regard this as a very grave indictment
of national security law and practice.
Is it also an indictment of
public interest litigation
aimed at constraining
national security abuses,
albeit quite a different one
than Judge Jacobs offered?
Did all of this failed litigation,
all of these dismissals
on justiciability grounds
unwittingly enhance the
prestige of the system,
and help reify the status
of national security law?
There's no question
that I and my colleagues
were actors in this theater of law.
And one could reasonably
argue that our participation
conferred undeserved legitimacy
on the whole sordid charade.
Yale's estimable Sam Moyn,
who is with us tonight,
has offered a different
version of that argument,
suggesting that the
litigation I've described
had the effect of making the
US's global war more sanitized
and thereby more sustainable.
Instead of litigating to
challenge the legality of war,
we chose to, in Moyn's words,
defend the rights of those swept up,
and in so doing may have
laundered the inhumanity
from what began as a brutal enterprise
by helping to recodify a war
that thus became endless,
legal, and humane.
In general, I find any suggestion
that my time could have been better spent
almost irresistibly compelling.
(audience laughing)
While much of our litigation did in fact
challenge the war paradigm,
I am not here to argue
that the cases I brought,
and the causes I championed
materially changed the
world for the better.
Still, what I find confounding
about Moyn's argument
is the suggestion that the decisions
of a handful of human rights lawyers
had any geopolitical significance,
and the implication
that had we devoted our
energies elsewhere or nowhere,
the course of the forever
war might have been altered,
or its foreverness foreshortened.
Whether public interest
litigation after 9/11
did more to legitimize or de-legitimize
national security law
and the war on terror,
will depend in the final analysis
on whether and how the legal community,
including the legal academy,
responds to the record of
impunity I've laid out here.
Will it continue to confer
prestige and dignity
on a regime that deems non-justiciable
some of the most vital questions
concerning the relationship
between state power and individual rights?
Or might the embarrassments
of these last two decades
compel the emergence of competing norms
that bring some measure of
democratic accountability
into this place of exception?
What would those norms look like?
First and foremost, the
doctrine of judicial deference
to executive branch expertise
has slipped its moorings,
and is now deployed, not to
respect separation of powers,
but to erode them.
The notion that courts are incompetent,
but the CIA is competent,
has always struck me as odd.
But even if there are
appropriately cabin instances
where deference is warranted,
it's judges, not leaders of spy agencies,
who possess the institutional competence
to weigh competing interests.
Courts should be especially on guard
for the structural conflicts
of interest that arise
when the putative expert
also represents the entity
accused of wrongdoing.
In those instances,
courts would do better to
begin with the assumption
that the executive is not credible.
Some years ago I was
invited to share a stage
at a judicial conference
with the late John Rizzo,
who had been the CIA's
acting general counsel
during the post-9/11 torture conspiracy.
The moderator of our polite debate
was none other than Judge Dennis Jacobs,
who is more gracious in
person than in print.
I don't remember much
about the event itself,
but I spent a fair amount of time
with John Rizzo over that weekend
as he smoked cigars at
an outdoor picnic table,
and held forth on the political
and intelligence leaders
he'd crossed paths with
during 34 years at the CIA.
This one was good for the agency.
That one hung us out to dry.
This other one was very
good for the agency.
The man unapologetically divided
the world into two camps.
That's understandable.
He didn't want his
friends to go to prison,
or have their careers derailed.
We'd be naive to expect otherwise,
but why in the world would we want judges
to defer to someone like this?
If John Rizzo was an expert in anything,
it was in keeping himself and his people
out of legal and political trouble.
All too often, demands for deference
have nothing to do with expertise.
Rather, they're demands
that courts treat national
security claims as absolute.
If the CIA director insists
that allowing a torture
victim his day in court
will complicate the agency's relationship
with the foreign intelligence service,
how that interest should be balanced
against other important interests,
such as providing a remedy
for an abuse victim,
or ensuring accountability for misconduct,
or resolving a
consequential legal question
is quintessentially a judicial function,
not a security function.
If courts refuse under
the banner of deference
to claim that role,
national security officials
will continue to be
the expert architects
of their own impunity.
The uses and misuses of secrecy,
which I've spoken about at
length these last two days,
present a distinct, but related challenge.
As we've discussed,
the government routinely
invokes secrecy doctrines
to shield from legal scrutiny
activities that are not secret at all.
The so-called official
acknowledgement doctrine, which holds
that even public information
is treated as secret
so long as the government
chooses not to confirm it,
has become an insurmountable
liability shield.
This is an accountability crisis
of the court's own making,
and the solution is straightforward.
Courts should stop treating
the government's asserted interests
as an all or nothing proposition.
They can accept that
there may be situations
in which official
confirmation of known facts
creates a distinct harm,
but not accept that the
judicial inquiry ends there,
if core values are at stake.
In other words, they can introduce
proportionality analysis,
which is very common
in other jurisdictions,
but has been completely alien
to US national security law in practice.
Even when secrets are
still actually secret,
courts have a vital role for
reasons that should be obvious.
Excessive deference
to executive branch
classification decisions
threatens any theory of
democratic governance.
If the president and his designees
have complete control over the information
by which we can judge their actions,
then the public can neither consent to
nor hold leaders accountable
for actions undertaken in our name.
At oral argument in the FOIA
case I discussed yesterday,
one judge challenged
me to cite prior cases
in which courts had overridden
executive branch classification decisions
in national security litigation.
I could not get past the
fingers on my first hand.
It's not hard to understand
judges' reluctance
when an executive branch security officer
shows up in their chambers,
with a briefcase handcuffed to his wrist,
and delivers a classified affidavit
from the director of central intelligence
attesting to the glaciers that will melt
and the oceans that will boil off
if a case is allowed to go forward.
Very rarely will a judge be
inclined to dig any deeper,
but they should dig deeper,
and they should consider these claims
against the backdrop of a long history
of gross exaggerations
and outright deceptions,
and they should do so with confidence.
The only people whose security
is likely to be jeopardized
are those who misuse secrecy
to conceal misconduct.
None of these changes in judicial behavior
are likely to occur,
absent a broader societal
shift towards resilience.
We've allowed rhetorical
excesses about a war on terrorism
to obscure the distinction
between acceptable and unacceptable risks.
Justice Brennan hoped that
judges would develop the capacity
to make those distinctions,
but judges are far more likely to reflect
society's relationship
to risk than to guide it.
The amorphous term national security,
which we apply indiscriminately
to efforts to prevent nuclear
proliferation on the one hand
and the arrest of inept knuckleheads
entrapped by FBI informants
into implausible terrorist
plots on the other hand,
isn't helpful.
The former is a legitimate
matter of national defense.
The latter should not be regarded
as a matter of any national importance,
much less national security.
We should scorn, rather than
aggrandize, political leaders
who refuse to acknowledge
that distinction,
and who equate the danger
of terrorism with world wars
in which millions of
lives were extinguished,
or a Cold war in which billions lived
under threat of annihilation.
My sense is that most Americans
spend very little time
thinking about terrorism.
And that institutional
incentives, not public fears,
best account
for how the most secure
society in human history
is kept in a state of legal emergency.
Those incentives will
be difficult to disrupt,
but we have to start somewhere.
And if any institution
should be at the forefront
of reasserting some sense of
moral poise rather than panic
in the face of ineradicable,
but non-existential threats,
it's the legal academy.
For all the ways in which the 9/11 attacks
reshaped our law and institutions,
the silence and shade that
still surround our efforts
to bring the alleged
perpetrators to justice
are truly remarkable.
This is the signal embarrassment
of national security law,
that in the 20-odd
years since the attacks,
the US has managed to
invade two countries,
and send our military into many others
to construct and then dismantle
a secret global detention apparatus,
to develop and deploy
systems of mass surveillance,
to create new domestic security agencies,
but has failed even to begin the trial
of the five alleged perpetrators
who have been in our
custody for two decades.
This might make an ideal starting point
for a course on national security law.
One that could not be
taught in a single sentence.
The course could explore
how grave misjudgments become
self-fulfilling prophecies
through a kind of bad faith syllogism.
First we decide that our
existing laws and institutions
cannot.
- [Cell Phone] Those ads
really drive you mad, the game.
(audience laughing)
- [Participant] Sorry.
- That's okay.
First, we decide that our
existing laws and institutions
can't accommodate the
detention, interrogation,
and trial of these prisoners,
so new rules are needed.
Next, we subject the prisoners
to such appalling mistreatment
that convictions under our existing laws
may in fact be impracticable,
but because we won't release
them under any circumstances,
we now need new rules
that will allow us to adjudicate
their crimes against us
while suppressing our crimes against them.
That these new rules constitute
a moral, practical, and legal disaster
that have caused decades of delays,
is almost beside the
point to their proponents.
The point of the rules was
impunity for the rule makers,
and it's precisely that impunity
that will make this paradigm
so difficult to dislodge.
If we're going to be
stuck in this paradigm,
as it appears we will be for some time,
let's at least insist on a
definition of national security
that encompasses more
than the never-ending menu
of threats against us.
Let's agree that a system
that deems the perpetrators
of grave abuses above the law,
and the victims of
those abuses beneath it,
should not be called secure.
And let's resolve that the
security of senior officials,
the architects and beneficiaries
of these states of exception,
will no longer be attained
at the expense of the security
of our laws and values.
Thank you very much for listening.
(audience applauding)
- [Participant] Thank you so much.
I'm wondering.
- Nice to see you again.
- [Participant] Nice to be back.
I'm wondering how you see
the national security regime,
as you call it, as having changed at all.
It seems our political
leaders have sort of moved on,
at least rhetorically,
from the war on terror.
So have you seen any sort of developments
in this national insecurity regime?
- Yeah, I mean one of the cases that,
thank you for that question.
One of the cases that
I discussed yesterday,
was so strange because
it was 2021 or 2022,
and the Supreme Court was
talking about Abu Zubayda,
and it was like, wow, we're
still talking about this,
and we're still saying
that what happened to Abu
Zubayda in 2002 or 2003
that everyone knows is a state secret.
So in one sense the
system has not moved on.
In another sense, you
know, I said yesterday
that this system is adept
at identifying new hosts.
I think sort of seeing the pivot
that the national security
set has made, you know,
to being self-styled
defenders of democracy
in response to Russian
propaganda, for example.
You know, now you have the war in Ukraine.
The whole cybersecurity issue writ large.
There's always an effort to,
you know, identify something
that will continue to justify
the massive budgets and authorities,
and that will require the secrecy
that is the keystone for that impunity.
So I agree with you
that there's not as much
conversation about terrorism
in part because we haven't
had much terrorism here,
and most Americans are
not talking about that.
But you certainly have
not seen any reduction
in the budgets of the
agencies that were created
to take this on, or really
any crack in the wall
of the kind of legal black hole
that the system represents.
- [Anna] Do you mind?
- [Hope] So thank you. That was great, hi.
I guess I had a similar question,
which is to ask you to
do a little bit of forecasting for us.
So since the years that you
and I litigated together,
I've done more work at the
international sort of level,
and something that's really striking
is that the US creates frameworks,
and in this case, plausible deniability
that of course then becomes a model
for many, many other governments,
and you know, in other places,
El Salvador being a notable example,
the National Security
framework now is being used
to go after street level gang leaders.
So I'm just curious if from
your view that, you know,
you talked about it being
a sort of a paradigm
that is able to find
many ghosts but hosts,
but I hope that you could just say
a little bit more about that.
And whether, and sorry,
and I guess just relatedly,
whether you think that that potentially
is a way in which the
politics around this change,
because one of the problems
in terms of mobilizing
support for doing the kind of challenges
that we've tried to do
is the fact that the people
were not only despised,
but they had no political
constituency within this country.
- Yeah, and so, you know, as you know,
I went from representing
torture victims in torture cases
where basically everybody agreed,
every reasonable person
agreed it was a problem,
but didn't think it had
any connection to them.
To working on issues of mass surveillance,
where most people didn't
think it was a problem,
but they all realized it was
connected to them in some way.
Right, but there, there
was an opportunity, I mean,
you know, you did have
significant political majorities
that were not partisan majorities,
that were pretty uncomfortable
with the revelations that came
out of the Snowden regime.
I mean, the reason why
the branches of government changed course
was because the public wanted that change.
So I do think that, you know,
to the extent that the government
abuses touch more people,
they create more opportunities
to change the political discourse.
You know, sort of looking overseas,
I would just say, I mean, as you remember,
there were clients who
we represented together
who were citizens of other countries.
The US got our cases dismissed
on the grounds that it would complicate
their relationship with those countries.
Meanwhile, the courts in those countries
gave remedies to our clients.
Right, and used other kinds
of analysis, and you know,
even even if they didn't
wanna litigate the cases
and expose their official secrets,
they realized that that meant
they should pay the victims
and not, you know, have this incentive
where they simultaneously
get to claim secrecy
and toss the victim out of court.
So one of the very frustrating
things about, you know,
doing human rights work in a US framework
is how little interest,
you know, US courts have
in being in conversation with
courts in other democracies
that face greater terrorism
threats than we do.
And yet find a way to adjudicate
some of these same kinds of disputes.
- [Participant] A totally
brilliant talk, so well delivered.
I just wanna, you know, hear
more about Edward Snowden,
'cause I totally accept
your critique of me,
but it seemed like you accepted
like a deep self-critique
in addressing what
Edward Snowden got wrong.
So I guess I'm a little perplexed.
- Wait, what he got
wrong, what he got right.
- [Participant] What he got right, sorry.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I accept, the self-critique
I'm really good at.
- [Participant] Yeah, so I just want,
I'm just trying to understand
the kind of credible pathway
to political change in the situation,
because you've said the judges,
we spent, you know, decades
we're still doing it,
asking judges for change,
which they will never deliver.
At the same time, you engaged
in a lot of idealization
of the constitution itself,
of the legal system, and
that's part of your shtick,
even as you acknowledge
that they're the problem.
And then Snowden makes more change
than legal activism ever
does by breaking the law.
So I guess I don't understand
what the political move is.
- It's a great question,
and it is a paradox.
Because the way that
Snowden creates change
is by breaking the law,
and thereby reinvigorating
legal and democratic oversight.
We basically only get energetic oversight,
judicial or legislative,
in response to leaks and law breaking.
The whole modern apparatus
of intelligence surveillance oversight
was a result of the Church Committee,
which was a result of a
bunch of anti-war activists
breaking into an FBI field
office outside of Philadelphia,
stealing all the files, and
mailing them to Betty Metzger
at "The Washington Post," right.
So like, basically, and
all of the, you know,
sort of limited successes that we've had
over the last decade,
you can trace to someone inside the system
deciding that the public
had a need to see something.
And then once the public
has that information,
I think lawyers and even litigators
are actors in that, right.
So we did file a successful lawsuit
based on documents that Snowden gave us.
It turned out that even
our unsuccessful lawsuit
was a critical piece of
bringing him forward.
And I know not from Snowden,
but from journalists
who got his documents,
that there were subfolders
in what he gave them
that were marked for the ACLU.
So that kind of conversation
goes on as well.
But, yeah, I take your point
that there is a, you know,
tension between my
disparagement of the system,
and my aggrandizement of how it should be,
and I can see that it's undertheorized.
- [Participant] I might just mention
that the Pentagon Papers
were another example.
The Pentagon Papers are another example
where there was an illegal release
then printed in "The New York Times"
and which had a profound impact
on the resolution of the
Vietnamese war and so forth, so.
- Yeah, I mean, interestingly,
Dan Ellsberg thinks it didn't,
he thinks he was years too late.
- [Participant] Well, he may
have been years too late,
but there's no question that.
- Yeah, well, there's other
parallels, which is that the,
you know, Nixon White House claimed that
Ellsberg had delivered a
set of the Pentagon papers
to the Soviet consulate or embassy in DC.
He was viewed as a spy and a traitor.
That was one of the cases that
I could put on my one hand
where a court actually said,
in the face of a government secrecy claim,
no, you haven't showed us enough
for us to give you this injunction.
And it's a good thing they did.
I mentioned this last
night, but, you know,
10 years after the
government lost that case
in the Supreme Court,
the Solicitor General at
the time, Erwin Griswold,
wrote an op-ed saying,
secret's not worth keeping.
He said in the decade that had passed,
he had never seen a shred of evidence
that anything in the Pentagon papers
caused any harm to national security.
I had never seen anybody
suggest that it had,
and that's why I say that kind of context
has to be part of court's consideration
of government secrecy claims,
because it costs the government nothing
to invoke secrecy doctrines
to protect embarrassment.
- [Participant] Oh,
thank you for your talk.
I wanted to ask if the ACLU
has heard about, and if so,
are they looking into the
following two allegations?
One is that the Iranian
general who was assassinated
during the Trump administration's tenure
had been attending a meeting to discuss
a peaceful negotiation of
settlement with Saudi Arabia
about the war in Yemen.
Like, I mean, that's one, yeah, I mean,
I could send you the source.
And then the second allegation
is Seymour Hirsch allegation
that US operatives working
in concert with Norway,
I believe, blew up the
North Stream 2 pipeline
that would have, that was
supposedly done last year.
So I just wanted to know if
you were aware of these things.
And looking into them.
- I'm aware of those things as a citizen.
They don't fall within
my professional remit.
I work for a domestic civil
liberties organization
that does not concern itself
with explosions in northern waters
or that kind of military operation.
So I don't have anything
particular to share with you there,
and it's not, I think,
the role of journalists,
not the role of the ACLU
to explore those allegations further.
- [Anna] Can you take the
microphone, take this real quick.
- [Participant] Can I
ask, in your ideal world,
what do you imagine a sustainable,
like, long-term mechanism
of accountability
to look like in the
national security space?
Because from your talk,
it sounds like currently
the only effective
mechanism of accountability
is relying on people to
break the law like Snowden.
- Well, I mean, it's a
really hard question,
and I always ask when
people ask me this question,
are you a computer scientist?
Are you?
- [Participant] Yeah, I'm a CIS agent.
- Yeah, because this is the conversation
I have with Snowden all the time.
He thinks that democracy is
a problem that can be solved
because he comes from
a technical background,
and I tell him that it's
actually not a solvable problem,
but just sort of, let
me give you an example.
So the last great intelligence scandal,
much bigger than the Snowden revelations,
in the 1970s when we learned about
the FBI's COINTELPRO program
where they were sending operatives
into Black student organizations
and the anti-war movement,
breaking up marriages, poison pen letters,
they tried to get Martin
Luther King to commit suicide.
All of this stuff comes out,
and the Congress's response
is to do three things,
two things, really.
So first they create
the House and Senate
Intelligence Committees,
they decide that congressional
oversight isn't working.
We need specialized committees
that have specialized access
to classified information.
We understand that the FBI
and the NSA and the CIA
don't wanna share information
with everyone in Congress,
'cause it will leak out, but
they can at least trust the,
you know, the 10 people on
each of these committees.
So we're gonna create these committees.
The second thing they do is they create
the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance court,
which can provide some judicial
oversight of, you know,
domestic intelligence surveillance,
not law enforcement surveillance,
intelligence surveillance.
And the interesting thing is that
the key insight of the Snowden revelations
was that 50 years later,
those solutions to the 1970s
problem were no longer working.
Right, the intelligence
committees in Congress
had been set up to do extra oversight.
It turns out they were extra captured.
The people on those committees
were the closest ones to the
intelligence communities,
not the ones who were
scrutinizing it the most.
And the court, which had been created
to authorize individual
intelligence warrants,
which is an appropriate
thing to do in secret,
was instead writing 90-page opinions
that were purporting to authorize
programmatic surveillance,
including collecting metadata
from every American's phone call every day
without hearing any adversarial arguments
from people who might say
that's not constitutional.
And so what was the
solution to the Snowden?
Well, now the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court
can invite in expert adversaries
who will come in, you know,
it's a tweak that was made to that system.
I don't have a structural
solution here, right.
I don't think that the structure is wrong.
You want an architecture
that divides power
between different branches of government,
but you need the representatives
of those branches of government
to take pride in that
independence and not consider it.
I mean, the dominant judicial doctrine
in national security law is
deference to the expertise of,
as I put it, the very perpetrators
of these abuses themselves.
And that's not an acceptable
mindset for judges to bring,
I didn't come here to talk to judges.
You know, the much more
modest goal here is, you know,
at least law schools should think about
what this body of law is before
they put it on a pedestal.
- [Participant] Thank you.
- [Participant] Hi. Thanks.
I wonder if you might
share any war stories
about being surveilled yourself,
either overtly or covertly,
at different times during your work?
- It reminds me of a
statement of Robert Mueller
when he was the FBI director.
I'm most concerned about
what we're not hearing.
No stories.
If it's happening,
they're good at it, yeah.
- [Anna] I think there was
another question on the back.
- [Participant] In the
context of talking about the,
our actual security date.
If 9/11 hadn't happened,
would the, I threw that in.
- I don't have an expert
answer to that question.
Yeah, here's what I will say
that it's not a direct
answer to your question.
That the reason why
the passage of new laws
after 9/11 was so swift
is that much of those laws
had been written before 9/11,
and the laws that will be passed
after the next terrorist attack
have also already been written.
- [Anna] There was a
question in the corner.
- [Participant] You know, you
paint a pretty bleak picture
about what's happening,
and the ways that this
whole national security law
is corroding a lot of our principles.
And I wonder if you could
just say a little more
about the FISA Court itself,
which is an Article III court
and therefore should perform
to certain constitutional standards
and how we have accountability
for the judiciary,
which is normally through public access
and public oversight.
And is this another example
of national security concerns
eroding our institutions
by undermining how our
Article III courts work?
- Yeah, I mean, if we
start seeing more courts
adopt the same kind of
secrecy practices of the FISC,
then for sure.
Look, I mean, what I said before,
I don't object to the existence of a court
that issues warrants in secret.
Even in public Article III courts,
warrants are issued in secret, right?
You don't send a note to someone saying,
we're authorizing a wiretap against you.
You go at an ex parte proceeding,
and a judge gives you
a warrant, that's fine.
The problem with the
FISC is mission creep.
That, I mean, if all the FISC were doing
were granting individualized warrants
at whatever the rate of acceptance, 99.9%,
that would at least be
performing, you know,
a function where we
don't traditionally rely
on an adversarial process
or even a public process.
Although with warrants, we
do expect that at some point
they can be made public after
the investigation is over.
And, you know, we've
been fighting for years
to get the FISC to do the same thing.
The problem is when you
have these broad authorities
that authorize the court
to issue broad programmatic warrants
that implicate constitutional rights,
and there's no one in the room
other than the Department
of Justice and the judge
to say, wait a minute.
And so again, one of
the post-Snowden reforms
is to give the court at
least the opportunity
to have an expert in the room
who is not the government.
But I think, you know, we
need to continue to push
for the release of their
historical opinions,
on an ongoing basis for
the reason you identify.
I mean, this is another problem
with classification, right.
Even for that absolutely
minute category of information
that is properly classified
in the first instance,
almost none of it should
still be classified
five years later, right.
- [Participant] Yeah, first it was
just a really wonderful talk,
and I apologize for being so late.
- The answer to your question
was provided before you arrived.
That's okay, yeah.
- [Participant] Oh, I'll pass, yeah.
I'm gonna struggle a little bit
to figure out how to ask this.
And I have a tendency I know
to ask sort of for a
prescriptive conclusion,
and I'm gonna try to avoid that.
But I feel like there's a way
in which the story you're
telling is generalizable
beyond the realm of national security.
And it seems like it's a story.
There's kind of a triangle
here between legal means,
social movements, and in this case,
important acts of civil disobedience.
And as someone who's
probably has less faith
in the power of law
than someone who teaches
law ought to have,
I guess I do have a question about
whether you think there are lessons here
about how change comes about,
and what role, what kind of relative role,
those three, to the
extent we can call them
three separate actors are,
the kind of, you guys,
an elite legal institution
trying to bring about change,
broader social movements
who seem to be motivated
on the one hand by the
inculcation of fear,
and on the other hand, by
the inculcation of outrage
when someone like Snowden can
bring it to their attention.
And whether that tells us anything
about how better to hold
the state accountable.
- Yeah, I struggled with this question,
and whether I should try
to come up with something
more prescriptive and oratory
at the end and say, you know,
other than just let's change our values.
And it's difficult,
and especially for one of the
reasons that Hope suggested,
which is that for a lot of
what we're talking about
the victims are invisible and abroad,
and so they're not going to be victims
around which we're going
to mobilize a movement.
The exception to that might
be when we're confronted
with horrific images of
sexual abuse, and, you know,
beatings and death at Abu Ghraib,
that can actually create some
kind of accountability moment.
But again, there you have it again,
there's someone inside the
system breaking the law
in order to put that in our faces
and to force that kind of response.
I think there are things
about the security context
where the politics are a
little bit unique, you know,
as I described,
where there's just no cost
to saying we need, I mean,
has there ever been in
any democracy, you know,
a good example of a public
punishing political leaders
for threatmongering, for fearmongering?
Maybe there are, you
know, as I said yesterday,
I haven't spent a lot of
time studying these phenomena
more being, you know,
kicked around by them.
But that would be worth looking at.
And I think in part, you know,
in the same way that the
government is opportunistic,
and is waiting for these, you
know, moments of disruption
to push additional authorities,
we probably should be
doing the same thing,
and know that we're going
to have these windows
that are created by, you
know, big media events.
I think you actually
we'll see that pattern.
That our big, kind of
high profile lawsuits
are filed six days after, you
know, the massive leak story.
And so we're kind of trying
to ride that wave in some way
and to make sure that that person's risk
is converted into some
legal or social change.
But I'm going to think more about that.
- [Participant] So thank
you so much for the talk.
I wanted to ask a question
about the relationship between
the national security state
and like the military budget,
and like the military
industrial complex more broadly.
Because I think you made the point
that rhetorically American
politics has kind of moved on
from the war on terror
as a source of fixation.
And one of the things that I thought of
is that despite that kind
of rhetorical moving on,
the kind of material
basis of that, you know,
that kind of rhetorical fixation,
the military budget has continued to grow.
And so I'm wondering the extent
to which you've experienced
a kind of integration
between the kind of broader
military industrial complex,
if that's not a cringey term and the
national security stage.
- And no it is, I mean,
I really think people, I think
that the Eisenhower speech
should be in more curricula.
It's short and it's really powerful.
Of course, he delivered that speech
as he was leaving office,
and if anybody could
have had the authority
during eight years in office
to do something about it,
it was the leader of the Allied
forces during World War II.
But even he, it was like,
I'll save this for my parting shot.
But no, I mean, you're absolutely right.
And the interplay between
that budget and classification
is another aspect of it.
There's a great book by
William Arkin and Dana Priest
about the sort of secret
surveillance budgets,
and even agencies that we
don't even really know about.
And these things get built,
they very rarely get unbuilt.
And you know, that's why I talked about
institutional incentives
more than public fears
are what's driving all of this.
- [Anna] There was a question.
I'll look to you and then
I'll come back to you again.
- [Participant] Hello.
I was thinking a little bit
about upstream collection,
and recently I heard a talk from someone
who used to work at the NSA,
and he said that one argument in favor
of upstream collection is
that, you know, it's not great
that we're collecting
information from US citizens,
but we currently just
don't have the technology
to filter out communications
that aren't about, you know,
what the NSA is actually targeting.
And until some magical filter
drops down from heaven,
this is the reality that we're left with.
- You know, there's another possibility
which is don't collect everything.
Right, it's true that if
you collect everything,
it's very hard to have a magical filter
that will tell you what's a US
citizen and not a US citizen.
But if you think it's a
problem that they're collecting
millions of communications
from US citizens,
a reasonable alternative would
be don't have that program.
Right, I mean, was that a
third option on his menu?
- [Participant] His
argument was that, you know,
in the interim we should just allow
the breaches of our constitutional rights.
- Well, I mean this is what,
you know, Keith Alexander,
who was the head of the NSA
for during the Snowden
revelations and before,
and a really brilliant bureaucrat
in the non-pejorative sense
of that word, you know,
his mantra was collect it all,
and the authorities and
the uses will follow.
We can't even know if it's gonna be useful
until we collect it all.
You know, I said this is like
going into a bar and said,
give me all of the drinks
so I can decide which one
I want to order, right.
We have to collect everything
because it might actually be useful.
And the thing is, that's true.
I mean, I think like
we need to actually say
that it's not helpful as a predictive tool
because if you collect every
communication in the world,
you've built the world's biggest haystack.
But it's extremely useful
as a forensic tool,
so that once something has occurred,
you have a surveillance time machine,
you can rewind into your database,
and the dots are always going
to connect in hindsight.
And that's why after every
kind of terrorist attack,
they say, if only we've
been allowed to search
all this information that we had,
we would've stopped that attack.
So you need to take down the wall
that prevents us from looking at that.
And I guarantee you this
is what would happen now.
Because you know, there
are some restrictions
on their ability to search
everything that's collected.
Although they do another
clever move, which is they say,
we're not targeting US citizens,
we're targeting non-citizens.
Okay, regrettably, we get
millions of communications
from US citizens.
Now we should be allowed to
search those communications
because they were lawfully collected,
because we weren't targeting
US citizens, right.
They call that the backdoor search.
And yeah, I mean, why
wouldn't they want to?
I mean, if you are in a security agency,
and it's your job to prevent
things from happening,
to solve bad things, if they happen,
of course they're gonna
want all of those things.
And I don't criticize this
person for wanting it.
It's someone else's job to
tell him he can't have it.
- [Anna] Can you pass the mic this way,
and you'll have the last question.
- We end where we began.
- [Participant] Thanks a million, Ben.
So this is more just a sort
of historical perspective
on your argument.
I mean, maybe for the
book more than for now,
but I mean it seems to me
how much 9/11 was really a turning point
is somewhat debatable in that, you know,
we've seen over many decades,
a drift of authority
over national security
from the other branches to the executive,
and a concentration of
authority within the executive.
And you know,
this really starts in
the Truman administration
where Congress, with the
blessing of the court,
gives up a lot of authority
over national security
to the executive branch.
And you know, also I
think, I mean I think this,
the 9/11 maybe was much more
of a scaling up of things
that had been going on for some time.
Even in the 1990s, the NSA
was already authorizing
a lot of surveillance and
using various legal loopholes
to get it going.
So I just, you know, it's
this sort of general trend
towards deference to executive authority
that's being intrained a very long time.
And it's not just sort of post-9/11.
- I think that's absolutely right,
and yeah, you could start with, you know,
Truman signing the National Security Act
on the Sacred Cow as Air Force one, right.
As we could start the lectures there.
I do think though that
it's a little bit more
than a difference in degree and scale.
So first of all, on the surveillance side,
the capabilities are night
and day different in 2006,
from 1995 even, and 2010 from 2006,
just the ability to collect the
whole world's communications
and store them at an affordable
cost, and then search them.
That didn't exist before 9/11.
That capacity was created after 9/11,
and the decision was made
to deploy it all in secret
before the public had any kind of say,
and then to install
that as an architecture.
And then I think the other
point is, you know, as I said,
you know, continuing to
redefine national security
to take on a longer menu of threats
that should not be considered related
to the national defense,
even like, you know,
lone wolf terrorists in the United States.
And so, but I think your
point is fundamentally right,
which is, I mean, I know this
because when I was trying
to litigate these cases
in 2006, 2007, 2008,
the government was citing
cases from the 1980s involving,
you know, surveillance
and the state secrets
privilege as well, so.
So yes, I think if I were going to have
more than two 50-minute lectures,
there would be a chart
that went like that.
- [Participant] Well,
there needs to be a book,
and you're the guy to write it.
- We'll see.
- [Anna] Wonderful, Ben, thank you so much
for this Castle lectures
and thank you everyone for
attending this today's,
it's really thought
provoking and fascinating,
and we look forward to seeing the book.
Thank you everyone.
(audience applauding)
(logo chiming)